jim stewardson how are you
i'm good man i'm good despite the fact
that you can't retweet me well you know
it happens it happens it happened you
it's your name
you were banned from twitter but you've
got this film and i wat i think you sent
it to me a couple weeks ago um several
weeks ago and
this thing is a great film it's about
what is about an hour long i think it's
45 minutes 45 minutes so it's a quick
watch but you really break down in the
film this q and on thing but i thought
it was so appropriate to have you on not
just to talk about this film but you've
been following these q and honors for
for a long time now since i think before
um the
2016 election was over you were
following some of these q and honors um
what and it wasn't really queuing on
them they've always rebranded right this
right-wing thing always does this
rebranding and these conspiracy theories
they always rebrand as they try to
regain do you think that's what trump's
doing with with fraud social do you
think that's what he's doing is kind of
trying to rebrand the q anon
uh absolutely i mean he's not even
trying to rebrand it right i mean trump
social is basically just q anon
uh there's really not much else going on
there except for mega propaganda
right and you're right that it was the
significant thing that trump did was
just re retreat uh two drops like
straight q drops right he retweeted a
lot of other people
uh who were kind of queuing on
propagandists many many times hundreds
of times when he was you know president
of the united states
amazingly uh but to my knowledge he had
never retweeted just a raw cue drop
before this one was a particularly uh
vile one uh q drop 11 i think was was
the one
and uh uh so it's significant that he's
just
directly talking straight to um q anon
victims is what i'll refer to them as
one i took a screenshot of one of his
his repost or whatever the [ __ ] they
call it over on fraud social but um when
he reposted this one it it has a really
long
um
letters you know and it says
um and i forget what the phrasing is but
it's their code we watched mike flynn
do this um this oh thing what what is
that what the hell is that thing that
they do um where we go one we go all is
that what is that what they say
uh it is what they say and it is what
mike flynn raised his hand to
on
[ __ ] july 4th right 2020. this is a
former general who's taking the oath to
our country
absolutely he still has three [ __ ]
stars on his chest which do not belong
there
um so so let me be let me let me like
not bury the lead mike flynn's cue
right literally so that is who q is
that's what you're saying uh that is
what i'm saying mike flynn has been um
running basically psyops on america
as you mentioned since the 26th before
the 2016 election
so what what i have done over the last
two years is sort of track
the entire progression of this you know
psychological warfare operation
um that has brainwashed a third of the
american public
if you look at what's going on out there
you look at the polls and literally
a third of the country has
completely delusional beliefs
and that is a result of a sustained
psychological warfare campaign
led by
retired lieutenant general mike flynn
it started with pizzagate and all of
that stuff he cooperated with wikileaks
julian assange roger stone guccifer all
of that [ __ ]
that was run by an operation called
maga3x
maga3x was started at the rnc at the
republican national convention in 2016
that was the convention where mike flynn
said lock her up
they started this project called mega 3x
and we have documentation about how it
all worked
and they ran the operations that started
pizzagate that
you know hillary is is sick she's
mentally ill all of those sort of memes
and operations will run out of this
this group called mega3x which was
started incidentally by peter thiel
mike flynn jeff gaseah who's peter
thiel's white supremacist henchman
um and jack posobik and a bunch of other
you know white supremacists
um and mega3x then after after they
successfully
stole the 2016 election through what
mike flynn calls digital soldiers
after that was done
they when mike flynn got uh pinched
for talking to the russians and then
lying about it to the fbi
that's when q anon started
because mike flynn couldn't talk
he couldn't talk because he
pled guilty
literally the week after q started was
when
mike flynn pled guilty
and then guess what happened after mike
flynn got his pardon
that was the cues last q drop in
december of 2020. so you're saying that
he could talk at that point
yes q was literally the period of time
where mike flynn could not talk
it talked for him well
but it's re-emerging here gabe
we've got jim here um
welcome gabe this morning um
and and we watched
because you bring up mike glenn jim and
gabe watched a a little clip that you
made a while back
and
this clip had a cult leader i forget
what her it's i forget what her name is
elizabeth claire profit that's it that's
it profit they use
they they even go as far as calling
themselves profit like changing their
name to the to profit i mean why
wouldn't you right i mean why wouldn't
you but no i think that's actually that
that was her husband's name and and oh
really actually yeah so that's just
happenstance
yeah you know and they
i i figured
i looked deep
i looked deep back yeah i actually know
uh her son sean prophet um who's a great
guy and and you know has
been speaking out
against it for for a long time
um but yeah i found uh a a
that mike flynn uh was
reciting literally
word for word a
cult prayer
from the 80s from this cult
called the church universal and
triumphant which was led by elizabeth
claire prophet
and mike flynn was reading
from it and having a christian church
read it back to him and this is an
occult prayer by a fascist cult leader
who's spewing theosophy which is this
you know
propaganda from you know the late 1800s
that has infested a whole lot of
conspiracy theories
well i've got your um it's called is it
called american mind [ __ ] is that what
the um that's it that's the dock yeah
that's the docs i've got it uh pulled up
here i want to play just the first
few minutes here jim so we can show the
folks what this film's about but then
then we'll talk about it on the other
side let's let's play it here just for a
bit
[Music]
there's a voltaire quote
if they can make you believe absurdities
they can make you commit atrocities
in a nutshell
that's what this is
there was a new phenomenon this week
something called q anon what exactly is
q anon and
why is it making headlines now here we
go
god bless america qn was a perfect storm
they had set this thing up since 2017
it created this huge radicalized
set of people
then the pandemic comes in retreat
tonight seeking isolation in the face of
the coronavirus the federal government
is taking new steps forward to fight the
panhandle president trump flanked by
major ceos and his task force announced
a national emergency and suddenly you've
got
100 million more people online well as
of today all but a handful of states
have issued stay-at-home orders a
shitload of time on their hands this
comes as alabama and missouri just
joined 40 other states that are urging
people to stay home that covers nearly
95.
there is concern fear will turn to panic
store shelves nationwide are dwindling
or totally empty like when i started
this or i saw what i saw
i told people i was like you guys
you don't understand will you [ __ ]
listen to me please
there are mounting questions now over an
alleged plot to overthrow michigan state
government and kidnap the governor told
them exactly what's going to happen
look at how they're driving
thank you and
it was difficult to be that crazy guy
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
and i have been trashed and harassed and
trolled and
[ __ ]
lied about
because no one wants to hear this
[Music]
well jim there you have it uh american
mind book um
thanks for sharing it with us because
it's a great film and i i've watched it
twice
once in regular time and then once sped
up because i wanted to re-watch it i
wanted to re-watch it because you have
so many good things in there
that i think will resonate with people
about
how this happened and really the perfect
timing with the unknown pandemic that
was coming during the election year um
it really played into the hands here
but you mentioned in the very beginning
of this a quote from voltaire can you
break down why that is so important here
um
yes
so the the fundamental thing that's
going on here again is is literally
psychological warfare they are
brainwashing people
right
the the reason why there's
so many people
uh that don't seem like themselves right
you hear this all the time like my aunt
i don't even like who who is this crazy
lady who's talking about you know rept
reptilians and [ __ ] like whatever
the brainwashing happens to be right
um it comes from um psychological
warfare it comes from brainwashing
people and brainwashing has been around
for a long time but it used to require
that you take somebody and put them in
like a compound right like in waco or
in jonestown or wherever you had to
isolate them and insulate them in order
to
shut off enough of the outside
information to to
to you know effectively brainwash them
it's not like that and
the internet right it's not like that
anymore
um with social media because you can get
pounded by this information
and that get that has been weaponized it
has been systematically
uh weaponized into a brainwashing system
i i agree i agree with you i think the
algorithm can isolate you right in the
information that you're reading
whatever whatever whatever
um social media website you're reading
that algorithm can isolate you from
other information me and gabe have
talked about this several times you know
the algorithm isn't the the enemy it
really is like garbage in garbage out
kind of thing exactly
and and that and that so so once these
people start to digest this stuff the
algorithm goes well this person's
reading this [ __ ] so let's feed them up
more trash and they'll read more trash
and stay on our website right so that
because the intention of the algorithm
is not the inherent evil it's
the people who are using the algorithm
to what you say brainwash which i think
that's what's happening because i've had
relatives that have
fell and fall to this and they don't
even know what's skewing up like they
don't even know they have no idea like
they're saying these things they'll say
stuff to me i'm like what you know
that's queuing on stuff they're like no
no i i read that on facebook like
yeah you read it
right q itself said in in 2020 stop
calling a q a stop call stop talking
about cues stop de-brand it
like literally q gave those instructions
um you know right before the election
like stop talking about q they've
they've kind of sniffed it out and
they're they're using it as a label so
stop talking about it like that and they
basically just transformed it to the big
lie
so
so
this this guy ron watkins right that
yeah you know people have been
claiming his cue which he told the guy
ran for a congressional seat got his ass
kicked
he had to loan his own campaign 95 000
in order to get like three points
that [ __ ] is not q
and anybody who thinks he is is getting
misled by bad actors and i'm just
telling you that [ __ ] straight up oh
no
i was gonna say the other thing is is
because there's the hbo documentary and
i think a lot of people
have been misled in that way because
there was that ambiguity of he kind of
made it seem like he was the leader and
then the documentary was like well
guess we got the answer and then
everyone yes that's it and now everyone
says like oh yeah ron watkins yeah
that's that q guy that's that q guy he
was the one who ran in arizona oh yeah
yeah this that like mike lindell you
know all this stuff
and then you know i mean it's one of
those things where it's like it seems a
little bit more nuanced than just ron
watkins right
it's not only more nuanced
ron watkins ran the website
that's it
you ran 8chan he was the administrator
of 8-chan so that little moment where he
gets caught or whatever ron watkins
knows everything
he knows everything right he was there
he he worked with this this woman tracy
diaz aka tracy beans to move q from
4chan to 8chan he cooperated with that
he said he basically had qsa were i'm
only going to post on 8chan now forever
and always which was a huge mistake by
the way but but they they said that
because ron watkins took ownership of
the the place where q posted
but that is a very very very different
thing from ron watkins's cue ron watkins
didn't write q drops he didn't
strategically figure out how to mind
[ __ ]
30
percent of america that was not ron
watkins he was just a [ __ ] who ran
the horrible website that you ran on
the guy who was who was operating it was
mike flynn with steve bannon and roger
stone and peter thiel and all these
[ __ ] monsters
um who are
intentionally trying to cause chaos in
america so that they can cause
an apocalypse and you know pick up the
pieces uh you know in their white
supremacist fantasy world
that's what this really is there was a
there was a video that i watched this
morning which i was like oh my god this
is gonna be great uh having jim on
because in the last several weeks
um trump and his allies have been trying
to stoke this
stochastic terrorism um through their
little their little hey there's gonna be
violence if this happens hey there's
gonna be a civil war if this happened
you know wink wink like hate another
insurrection type [ __ ] right
but that that didn't go very well and
the reason why is because democrats
didn't just go like oh they're just
being
silly
democrats like you [ __ ] terrorists
and and they really and joe biden leaned
into this and they really had to back it
off so much so that you have videos like
this that are coming out and i believe
this is an effect of this where they're
trying to what you said rebrand right
they rebranded from this to q and on
from q and on the big lie and now that
people are like you q and honors you
republicans you moglodites are [ __ ]
dangerous and you're violent and you
want to overthrow our democracy they're
trying to rebrand again right and that's
what this social media post is from
whoever this
lady is um but i think more than who she
is is more important of
listen to the script she's saying
because it feels like to me
she's heard this somewhere and she's now
repeating it into a social media post
listen
so as the midterms get closer there's a
couple of things that is patriots we've
got to keep in mind
one is that the deep state really wants
to
trigger and set off patriots to entice
or provoke them into violence
so so and i'm going to pause it a couple
times here because there's a few things
that she says that i want to make sure
we we we talk about before it [ __ ]
seeps into people's minds because it's
all complete [ __ ] number one um this
is this cat call for terrorists as
patriots right
they've totally they've totally taken
this word patriots uh under their own
wing and like yeah people who hate the
united states who love trump who want to
overthrow their government they're
patriots like what the [ __ ] are all
fascists do that right right it's it's
it's national nationalism uh is that
always a cloak for fashion well
christian nationalism like national
socialism you know those socialist nazis
who weren't socialists at all i mean
it just
um it's it's it's par for the course for
fascists to do this and to try to set up
a fascist state the other thing the
other thing that she says here is that
she brings up the violence almost
immediately um right and that's really
what she's trying to say is don't commit
violence because they say we are violent
and listen to what she says after which
it seems like projection let's listen
and no matter what happens
we can't allow that to happen
we must follow the rule of law we must
use our voting power we must write our
legislators we must we must stand up and
say no when appropriate
no matter what happens whether trump
gets indicted or even if he gets
arrested or worse
we cannot resort to violence we cannot
become what they are
so i mean you gotta i mean you gotta
love the projection right i mean the the
party is
i mean i will say this you gotta hand it
to the republican party and trump
because they are professionals when it
comes to projection and hypocrisy they
will whether it's
uh fascism it's uh you know being sexual
predators with the economy whatever it
is
they will be like oh we can't be like
them
it's and it's like they're it's like
they're delivering the speech in the
mirror right like in an unironic fashion
they're practicing
talking to themselves but it really is
them saying it to themselves like we're
the problem we are the actual issue but
we can't be like them and them is us
because i'm pointing at you which is me
and we're the pro like
that's what it is exactly so so the the
the super power that all these
[ __ ] have is shamelessness
right
seriously like sociopathy psychopathy
which is what all these guys are
sociopaths or psychopaths or some
version of have no empathy whatsoever
that gives them the ability to be
completely shameless
and just live 40 000 times or however
many times that trump did you know for
four years right like
he doesn't care it doesn't affect him at
all that other people know he's lying he
doesn't care it doesn't matter because
it's just about you know
um
his
him
and so what she's doing in my opinion is
is saying
you know wink wink not not uh there's
gonna nudge nudge there's gonna be
violence but it's their fault
right well and i think i think she's
saying that like she's doing the wink
wink nudge nudge not not thing like hey
he's gonna get indicted he's gonna go to
jail
and they're the ones when violence
happens they're the ones to blame like
you're saying is that is that what
you're saying here is that she's saying
yeah totally yes right and i'm seeing it
everywhere so
it seems like a script does this seem
like a script to you this is 100 she's
reading she's reading yeah like i mean
she's obviously reading from
the other thing that makes me think of
is is how
it is the self-fulfilling prophecy right
they're like guys these guys are we
don't we don't want to be violent but if
they make us violent then that's not on
us right that's on them
and it's that conversation you you hear
the same thing with uh
um with charlie kirk right on fox news
and he's like joe is she or uh
joe biden is calling us fascist and it's
like oh if they really want to cause
fascists like we can call him something
even worse and it's like
you are now being like there's a light
that is being shined on that group of
people to expose them for who they
really are and what they really believe
in and those people are now saying well
okay well now that you've put the light
on us and you're saying that we're this
thing then i guess we'll just be the bad
guy we've just got to be the bad guy now
and what the reality of it is is like oh
[ __ ] we've been exposed and now our only
play is either to double down on us
actually being fascist or
retreat and try to rebrand into
something else
right yeah they're not retreating yeah
right that like pedo hitler remember
that trend oh yeah right after this is
right away right well i mean i mean
that's that's the thing is is that it's
always projection but listen here
because the gas lining in the projection
gets even worse it gets it gets it gets
even darker it gets even darker here the
projection in the gas light listen
because if we do if we give them any
reason
they'll they'll round us up in large
numbers they're dying for the chance to
either arrest us or to
bust us off at the fema camps and will
never be seen again so just don't give
them that satisfaction
fight
but peacefully
the second thing is is that
if if there is a scary false flag and uh
i'm pretty sure there's going to be
something that's going to scare people
keep in mind
everything is going as planned
so here's this other gotta trust you
gotta
she says she says that she projects the
thing about fema concentration camps
like look it's not hard to crowd you
people up all you got to do is promise
your orange deity will appear in a
cattle pasture and you dumb
[ __ ] were all crowded there
it's not hard to crowd your sheep up it
really isn't and it's not hard to spot
you [ __ ] to know how dumb you
are we don't need that we don't we i
i really honestly i believe in free
speech jim i believe in freedom of
expression and i think any dumb
[ __ ] that wants to put on a make
america great
again hat so i know they're a stupid
bastard i welcome that that would be
great if you felt that way about
the rest of america that you hate
america and you're so [ __ ]
un-american that you would wear that
nazi hat i would i will i will gladly
welcome you to wear that so i know not
to
get near you because you're a dumb buck
but this lady here this the saddest part
about this whole thing
is she really like you said earlier has
been brainwashed this isn't like this
lady is some kind of [ __ ]
q anon operative that's trying to trying
to push this great scheme and trying to
you know
get liberals in a position this lady has
been completely brainwashed she believes
this [ __ ] that's the actual effect
that's the effect that steve bannon
donald trump uh donald trump jr
michael flynn all it's sydney powell all
these [ __ ] traitors that mike lindell
the all these people that's the effect
that they want is someone like her
believing this garbage so much so that
she'll make a [ __ ] video repeating
this absolute gaslighting absolute
nonsense to make it look benign right
because when someone sees this
go ahead go ahead it's a requirement for
them to be propagandists right to not
only consume propaganda but to to then
reproduce it
that that's part of part of what's so
[ __ ] pernicious about it is that in
order to be accepted into the community
in order to get that sort of the the
social love bombing effect which is a
requirement for this kind of
brainwashing
um you you gotta reproduce the
propaganda you gotta be part of the team
you gotta be part you know on the on the
you know right side
uh in order to prove yourself and it
just increases the level of of
engagement which increases the depth of
of the undue influence which is the sort
of more proper term for
for brainwashing
um and and i also want to say something
about free speech real quick
uh
free speech that hurts people is not
free
the person who's getting hurt is [ __ ]
paying for it
right
and so so the the people like trump and
bannon and and especially mike flynn who
are out there you know claiming free
speech when what they're really doing is
intentionally
um you know psychologically hurting
people
that's [ __ ] not free speech because a
lot of people are paying for it both the
people who are getting hurt themselves
and their loved ones right well and
that's a good point because i would
almost bet just looking at this lady
that she's probably somewhere in the
midwest um
she seems like she probably has a child
that um that has went through college
and she had to co-sign on big ass loans
um you know federally subsidized loans i
would imagine that she lives on she gets
a social security check maybe she has a
teacher's retirement or something i'm
just guessing here and i i but i would
imagine she has medicare and these sorts
of things and if you really sat down and
went like hey let's talk let's not talk
about crazy theories let's talk about
what your community can do for you and
what what what help you need in your
community should be like my community me
at my kitchen table well number one my
medicare is too damn expensive my social
security's not high enough i'm terrified
that people are gonna take it away from
me my damn kid is is up to their
eyeballs so much so in college debt that
the son of a [ __ ] still lives with me
and he and and they got a great job
because of the degree but it still
doesn't pay worth of [ __ ] to pay back
the student loans they don't have
[ __ ] health care because they can't
afford it so we've got that risk going
on i mean it just on and on and on it
could go right and you could sit down
and talk to these people
and that is what i think democrats have
finally started to come to the table to
do to unwind all this because
are you in agreeance that democracy is
the thing that can unwind this because i
truly believe that because you just
mentioned free speech and and i'll push
back on you a little bit i believe that
um we do have to we do have those
dangers because we have that liberty um
but what we have to do as citizens of a
democracy is participate and engage and
it can stave off some of that so do you
think democracy real true democracy
where people are engaging not just again
marking a ballot but talking to their
their community members their family
their fellow parishioners their
colleagues and having these
conversations do you think democracy is
the thing that can unwind this
um well democracy is the thing that this
is attacking right
so it's it is yes and no uh the the
issue uh the issue is that
what what is
the effect of this is that democracy is
being eroded right both from the top
down they got a [ __ ] russian puppet
in there for four years to destroy it
from the executive down
and now they're doing all this
local action has a national impact which
is what mike flynn's like slogan is
which means that they're going to all
these school boards and local election
boards and trying to destroy the fabri
and law enforcement very importantly
right they're doing this constitutional
sheriff's thing where they're literally
getting entire police forces on on you
know the wrong team
so so
for me
yes democracy is absolutely
um
something that can fix this but the
thing that can really fix this is the
[ __ ] rule of law
that is fundamentally what this country
is is a a place where we all agree to
live by certain laws and so what needs
to happen is these [ __ ] who are
committing crimes who are spies and and
traitors to this country who are
planning insurrections who are creating
these these psychological traps for for
people those [ __ ] need to go to
prison and when they do the rule of law
will have uh will have saved our our our
country and then we can start to
actually exercise our democracy because
it's very difficult to exercise their
democracy correctly when it's being
attacked by all these bastards well
thank you for coming to make that talk
yeah yeah well rule speaking of rule of
law i got a clip here um boy you led me
right into um the rule of law throwing
down the hammer um what it seems to be i
think it's six counts is what i'm
counting that he was charged with this
morning um this is this is great this is
one of the greatest piece of footages
that you'll see in a couple weeks this
is steve bannon still trying to play the
victim as he walks into the the
courthouse here and listen to the lady
at the end oh no i don't know who she is
but god bless her she's great
they're persecuting people here
take a step back
[Music]
[Laughter]
ah
oh you greasy two-bit grifter i don't
know who she is someone please send her
a bouquet of [ __ ] flowers somewhere
ah that lady that the lady deserves
lunch free for the rest of her life holy
[ __ ] i mean you got it you gotta hand it
to to steve bannon he can launder money
but somehow he can't launder his own
clothes like the guy is a he is a slob
everything he just keeps putting clothes
on top he's like i got a shirt i got a
polo i got a button up i got a jacket
like i've never seen i've only seen like
three outfits it's like a striped shirt
with a camo jacket it's this all black
multiple shirt thing like he's just he
puts on all the shirts at the beginning
of the week and then takes them off or
he just adds them on every day but every
time he's made an appearance in like
professional
kind of uh an outfit it's always been
this i'm wearing a black shirt on top of
a black shirt on top of a black shirt
with a black jacket you know it's
that's never been washed never been
watched yeah yeah yeah here is here's
the spiro agnews ghost as it uh tweeted
from earlier it says breaking steve
bannon is charged in uh new york with
two counts of money laundering three
counts of conspiracy and one count of
scheming to defraud now this sounds like
like trump org in general right like two
counts of money laundering three counts
of conspiracy this is like their motto
like they got it written down somewhere
that this is what they're doing but
there's something there's there's
something else uh i don't know if anyone
remembers this but back in 2020 that
when the build the wall was uh
was um
was started right they were fundraising
for the program you mean i mean this
actual one that he's been doing this
actual one right that's connected to i
think it's what fisher uh
well yeah there's still there's still
people that are federally charged with
this that right didn't pardon he just
pardoned steve bannon because
you know
so so i so what i was saying was i don't
know if people remember the fact that
back in 2020 trump actually gave his
blessing
to
fisher industries and steve bannon to
build the wall he actually personally
tried to and repeatedly tried to lobby
for
uh
1.2 billion dollars to go to the wall
that was down there because of course
you know trump his family and wall is
falling down and he can't get that thing
up and in
and and have anything that lasts long
right
i mean all of that [ __ ] is just falling
apart where now we have to invest more
money to actually repair the damage that
he did by building a wall
but in doing so like he gave his
blessing to a private group that was
fundraising like yeah do it do it and
then tried to lobby money
to this exact same group so it's not
surprising one that this group is you
know obviously getting investigated and
indicted for fraud and money laundering
but like the fact that trump our
president at the time had his hands
mixing around in that pot of fraud
his tiny hands
well you know i actually um yeah
steve bannon's lawyers have uh produced
a picture here of his response to the
charges the six charges that is brought
um and i just want to make sure people
people know that steve bannon
this is the i don't know i i i i don't
know i don't know this is just the
picture that this is pretty close
man
i don't know who made this but [ __ ] it's
good you're telling me that's that's not
an arraignment photo right well that
this may be this may be his booking
photo here i don't know i know somebody
needs to put some numbers
all right under don't do that whatever
you don't don't make this into a booking
photo for steve bannon and post it on
our podcast account
and too bad we can't tag jim on twitter
i don't know
oh man oh man but uh no i i i love that
picture of steve bannon it's the best
picture of him um and here speaking of
pictures i don't know who this is but we
need to find her this is the lady um who
was uh who called him the greasy two big
grifter yeah two big hero
well she's uh she's taking over for bill
maybe you know bill the guy who did the
whistle guy
no the guy that has a guy inside he's
been behind uh uh he was behind all
these guys
okay he was the one he was also the one
that was by behind peter navarro oh yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah he's the guy that's
got the whistle on the long side that's
it but he's been doing it since like
2017 like like a long time
well because the reason why is because
he's in washington right it's amazing
yeah yes exactly he's in dc so this was
in new york so he someone wants to help
so it's a so so bill maybe bill reached
out it was like hey right right you do
new york
well it happens it happens well i think
i think um justice is coming for these
folks and the other uh the other news uh
and i think we're gonna have dakota
adams on to talk about this uh hopefully
we'll be able to record something with
him soon about the oath keepers news uh
stuart rhodes
stuart rhodes uh is actually going to
have to go to trial i assumed because
most of the time when
a defendant
fires their legal team and gets a new
legal team that legal team gets time to
prepare and that's their case and the
judge normally grants it the judge is
like nope that's enough of this [ __ ] no
this is a [ __ ] i want to try please
stop right no [ __ ] way you're not
gonna you're not you're not slowing it
down so we're gonna so we're gonna see
this trial start um for
uh for stuart rhodes the founder of the
oath keepers the
the the person who was looking for a
direct line um to donald trump the day
of the insurrection to bring the qrf
across the
potomac
um to commit violence
and actually overturn our government and
that is the thing so i think the rule of
law is coming for these people and me
and gabe have talked about these
classified documents that this [ __ ]
buffoon stole from us um and harbored
them down in in mar-a-lago no telling
who he showed them to or sold them to or
ate them i think he ate some of these
things i think he got hungry
there's a lot of empty folders
yeah i mean i'm sure he is you know
paranoid right i mean
of course why he's freaking out about
baron's room and and melania's drawers
and all that stuff like he is very much
paranoid about the fact of they got
something that i hid behind the xbox or
whatever it might be
and they took it and now it was in his
desk it was like you know well yeah yes
well i can't remember like this
the most sensitive [ __ ] was like
right
if i had to imagine what the layout of
these documents were in mar-a-lago like
we know like oh it was in the pine hall
room which is just kind of an open area
we we have uh his desk and this and that
right
it's almost like he was like setting up
for like an easter egg hunt right like
he just had these folders randomly he's
like oh it's behind the chimney or like
it's behind the couch or it's on the
ground and it's like oh looks like you
found it if you find it you get to keep
it right you're trying to cancel easter
you're trying to cancel easter they
won't cancel easter we will have an
easter egg classified document hunt here
at mar-a-lago
jim thanks for joining us do it here's
what here's what i want you to do i want
you to plug your sub stack and plug
anything you want do a shameless plug
here
for the audience tell them where to find
you i've got your sub stack and the
movie link down in the description so
everyone after the show go check those
out but do a shameless plug here jim
oh just uh come join me on my sub stack
i write frequently uh multiple times a
day
about all these asshats
um and uh i i'd love for you to
check it out and subscribe if you like
it
um and and please especially if you have
a chance take a look at my documentary i
think for a lot of people it's been
helpful um you know and there's a lot of
people who don't want you to see it so
that's probably the best reason to do it
well all those links are down
in the description below and definitely
don't just watch
the american mind [ __ ] share it with
some of your relatives that may have
fell prey to this q anon conspiracy
theories and this brainwashing that has
happened
to our country jim thanks for joining us
come back any time my friend um we we
love having you here we'll talk we'll
talk to you soon my friend everyone
stick around we'll be right back with
the shitless roundup we're going to surf
the tweety tweets and trendy trends
right when we come back stick around
don't go anywhere